[Music]
what are we doing now that I've stopped
so we're gonna crash out alright what
does that mean you know it sounds like I
sometimes say to the crowd right we're
gonna crash out now and they they act
like they have to do something okay like
maybe there's a mechanism under their
seat they need to operate it's just a
show business term that means we're
ending the show abruptly abruptly so so
we're not saying thanks to Bill Byrne
yeah thanks I'm sorry gang by the way
you guys are so great I'd happily do
another one if we had any material I
really would yeah I'm talking to you
Jeff Ross piece of the show and you said
can you do two want to do two with Bill
and I said didn't you offer me I was
told there was two you would say that
good name too but how do I do - if I'm
just crashing out now is this would have
been the other out Howie would crash out
from me we would leave from the
interview
what do you show me legal documents for
but is this supposed to mean to me I'm
an idiot I'm supposed to do that you
know in the epicenter with intense looks
on their faces we're going out real hard
crashing out man crash it out oh he's
gotta get out of here what count me down
and I'll do it yeah sure
he's taping a game
[Applause]
you
you